Next, we'll look at how to set up our Live Link facial performance inside of Unreal Engine.
So to get started, we need a couple of things first.
We need to make sure that we have a computer that is running Unreal Engine.
If you have Unreal Engine 4.25 or later, the plugins will become automatically active.
However, you might need to go in and enable the plugins which we'll touch upon in a second.
You also need some kind of iOS device on either iPhone X or later, or an iPad Pro and later,
so that we can have this Live Link functionality.
And we've got a link to the documentation if you need to understand how to set up blend shapes
for the different characters produced by the ARKit's facial recognition there.
So we've essentially got five plugins that we want to enable here.
If you're unsure where to find plugins, just go to Edit at the top of your editor,
go down to the Plugins box, and you can type in in this search box the plugins that you're looking for.
So first of all, type in Live Link. We want to just enable these three Live Link plugins.
Once you start enabling one plugin, it'll ask you if you want to restart your editor.
Don't restart it just yet. Just make sure you enable all the plugins first and then restart your editor.
So we've got three Live Link plugins and then we've got these two
ARKit and the ARKit Face support here. So let's just enable all of these plugins.
Then it'll ask you to restart your editor, hit Yes, and then after the restart,
all the plugins will automatically be enabled. You could sanity check this and just double check
that you've ticked all the right ones after the restart, but just make sure these plugins are
loaded before you continue. The next few steps are a little bit more complicated.
Just make sure you take your time in this section, go step by step, maybe refamiliarize yourself with
the information. We've got a few pages of debugging as well after this section, if things aren't
connecting correctly, but essentially you just need to get your computer talking to your iOS device.
So we need to figure out how to get Live Link connected between our iOS device and the computer.
So we can go to the project settings, so go edit project settings in your editor,
and then we've got this UDP messaging section. We want to look up the computer Unicast endpoint here
and find that, and this will be used as a subject target in a second here. So the Unicast endpoint
is the number that we're looking for here. Now we want to launch Live Link Face app on our iOS device.
We want to then tap the gear icon to open the settings and tap the Live Link settings option
and then add the target here, the IPv4 address to the targets, the IPv4 address that we just found.
I'll show you how to grab that in a second here if you're unsure how to find your
computer's local IPv4 address, but that's essentially what we want. And then the Live
Link Face calibration, we want to tap the calibration settings, enable calibration and countdown,
and then the calibration icon will appear on the screen there. Now back over in Unreal Engine,
we'll need to open our Live Link window. So again, we can go to Windows,
Live Link. I believe Live Link is inside the virtual production sub tab there, but again,
if you are using a more recent version of Unreal Engine, you can just type out Live Link and it'll
open up that window and then you can pin it to your editor somewhere. And then we want to select
the source subject as the iOS device, which is this section here. So this should automatically
be detected. If you're not getting this green light, you could just hold on a second to check
out some debugging tips in a second, or you could repeat the previous step. But at this point,
we need to be able to see this green light happening here. And then if we have, say,
in this example, we're going to use a MetaHuman for the facial performance. So we've got our
MetaHuman in the level here, locate the default tab in the details panels, which you can see here
in the default section, select your Live Link face subject, which is the iOS device, and then
check on the Live Link face head for rotation. So you can use PlanEdit to view
facial performances out of the box here. And then at this stage, it's probably useful for us to
get familiar with the interface of the Live Link app setup. So in a similar fashion to how we did
the take recorder, we've got an option here to open the settings dialog. We've got an option here
that toggles sending facial animation data to all Live Link targets. And then in number three,
we've got a toggle for the video display, the facial tracking on and off. Again, we've got a
nice big red button which starts and stops the recording. In number five, we've got open a list
of all takes previously recorded by the app. Number six is showing the current slate and take,
similar to how take recorder operated here. And then number seven basically just displays,
essentially indicates that the app can detect your face and capture everything correctly.
So again, we've got some great documentation, which is well worth a read, how to approach
facial recordings in Unreal Engine, which is worth a read as you're doing this.
So as promised, we've got a couple of slides here for some debugging information,
just to see if things weren't connecting with Live Link correctly, how you might go about
fixing this. So as we stated at the top here, we just want to make sure that the plugins are
enabled. Just go ahead and double check that plugins are enabled correctly. Restart your editor as
well when you're enabling plugins, you want to make sure that the iOS device and computer are
directly connected, which means no signal repeaters as well. And we want to verify both
iOS device and computer IPv4 addresses connected. So you can either find out your IP by going on
What's My IP, which is a URL that you can follow, or opening the command prompt in Windows, you can
type in IP config. And that will give you your IPv4 address at the bottom here, which you can see
located there. We want to verify our own the same subnet and also verify computer IPv4 addresses in
the settings of the Live Link face app. So just make sure those two addresses match. The static
endpoint port number is optional. So you could try if you still have an issues to add that port
number, but it is completely optional. And then we also want to check in the UDP messaging section.
We want to add UDP messaging for stability here, and then verify a single instance of Unreal is
active. Then we want to just make sure our firewall is disabled here. Check any whitelist
devices and incoming rules, and also verify that the app is on and actively capturing data.
If all else fails, reset or restart all devices and just try again. The UDP messaging is located
in the plugin section of the Unreal Engine project settings, as we said before. And here
is some information on the different endpoints of what you might be looking for if devices aren't
connecting correctly.